radu l'amore e dvd video di mycroft c'è
la via da bella faccia non ho mai avuto
un amico mai
grazie my boy si fa via degli amici veri
porco demonio mai lasciato ma si basi
pazzo due diamanti ma sono trova non
posso accettare amico mio sono troppi
considerando tutti quelli che ho perso
non solo niente però avere un fa niente
se mi hai fatto un regalo incredibile
maghrabi dovrò ad evitare in qualche
modo che cosa questo serve per
raccogliere le cose ci sta mettendo un
sacco anche perché ci mangiamo a vicenda
le miniere no perché siccome non serve
dove ci sta un sacco di persone presenti
sono offerti dobbiamo cercare di non
prenderci le risorse a vicenda non è
facile quindi è un regalo che apprezzo e
tanto anche grazie fratello vi faccio
una bella squadra in diamante la faccio
subito perché effettivamente melai
massime ammesse proprio in fila dalla
serie fatti la spada è stato proprio
gentile e io utilizzerò tutto per farmi
la spadina grazie brother sei proprio il
super gentile bene allora facciamoci in
questo momento va primo dell'ego no
cenno di cheste libere dopo che parla me
ne faccio al 33
perché mi serve necessariamente spazio
ragazzi non c'è più spazio e devo fare
assolutamente spazio tra tutte le cose
ordinatamente ok boys questo upgrade a
volevo iniziare ragazzi ad abbellire un
pelo di più casa orco demonio kasami
all'interno perché effettivamente fa un
po cacare ma perché non c'è quasi più
niente sarebbe interessante vedere se
riusciamo a fare anzitutto questo tre
cartelli bacheca chiama il design i
cartelli brigata servono non capiti e
l'efficienza dei cartelli ma vela
insegno io guardatele sugli spiega il
signor favi a cosa servono i cartelli
fidatevi che servono allora i cartelli
anzi anche le scale aspetta questa roba
a casa mia io la usavo a casa mia anima
e proprio davo per fare le i divani
questo è un mondo convenienza c'è roba
che fatta dal fai
quindi sta roba e mega utile e rende
tutto molto più poi c'è rimasta ancora
dell'edera ma la tengo perché mai carino
silicon c'è almeno ricorda affatto in
questa era non era proprio una casa
all'inizio non solo un albero trova
invece in eccesso va bene possiamo
rimettere di comunque ragazzi è solo
l'inizio di come fare a casa mia perché
effettivamente io voglio utilizzare
questi rail come avevo detto per farne
per collegare anche gli altri alberi
perché farò estenderò la mia casa sugli
altri alberi sono prove incredibile
comunque a vedere cosa sta facendo 7
fair e vediamo se raggiungerli ma prima
di tutto gode knowles marmo e for my
brother fernandez a loro e quindi
prendiamo questo prendiamo l'espada però
non prendiamo niente di più perchè ho
paura di perderlo quindi prendiamo robe
che servono relativamente fernando il
mio come stai che rivesto chissà adesso
mia fernando anche arma tour bar da
qualche cavallo destriero incredibile
tedesco a raggiungere sempre ferie o
cosa stanno facendo largo o che piacere
andare a cavallo organico fernando
vediamo se riesco a troppo alto ma le
perdiamo del cibo
è tutta roba che serve alla pecora palco
tutti vabbè mi serve roba ragazzi realtà
perché da un po chi è che ha tagliato
albero così forse sono stato fernando
dobbiamo fare amicizia e non è se non
fare come fai di solito che non cali la
gente sia un'abile perché è importante
che i ragazzi capiscano che siano
amichevoli cosa che lo stanno gia
facciamo anche video insieme per ora non
si sa mai sony panda eccoci ciao ragazzi
tutto a posto
voi siete i prossimi che cavalca e non
so come me aveva se c'è stanno era e non
ho tipo quando ci sono era un tipo ii
può essere li ho trovati per caso che
sono uscito da una miniera ma non li so
trovato adesso che sono in superficie
cioè ridicolo
sono entrato dentro che bello che bello
ciao amici cose che avete aspetta in
segno di amicizia del palco per terra e
quel segno di amicizia prendi per e
prendi tep chiunque prenda e poi ti da
64 di bambù che semplicemente il vostro
semplicemente io l'ho preso per arrivare
fino qua adesso me ne vado ciao stato
molto divertente
allora ragazzi casa via è abbastanza
accogliente precari sono ancora quelli
trino non pensavo non so perché in
realtà volevo avessero fatto già una
distesa enorme invece si sta aprendo il
loro tempo magari hanno trovato che ha
un sacco di materiali eccolo contendente
della questa perché ne ho una e l'ho
fatta per sbaglio quindi a voi scegliete
pare appendere no prendi anni o al picco
in diamante va bene a breve ad haifa
niente allora voglio delle spiegazioni
come nato fernando a fernando è nato no
non è che ne son mica ma con la sua
madre l'ho visto da la stella a noi
certo la sella l'ho trovata a no ma tu
non sai una cosa incredibile ma che non
sai una cosa incredibile
marra forse te l'ho detta in un bosco
alla presente nello scorso mercato non
ascoltato il vocale no no no no no tu
non hai idea allora io sai che se le si
trovano nei dungeon ok lo trovate in un
dungeon con marce trovato il nec
e poi ho fatto lembi e ho messo on line
tagga fernandez e fin qua incredibile
tutto in un episodio di assurdo
nell episodio dopo ho trovato io a casa
un dungeon ok ok
e la cosa incredibile è che io ho
trovato sto d'angelo preso le rovescio
netto no non ci hanno trovato un altro
mi schiavo sopra la testa
esco ed esco a casa vostra ma degno
sotto casa vostra giunta c'era un
dungeon io sono uscito c'era ve lo giuro
è ultimo a priori tanto senza rumori
stato ma non mi ci ma non vicino sotto
sotto casa vasca il dritto so c'è un
dungeon devo andarci viene pagata al
sicuro insomma incredibile città dove
sono queste febbre di sonic rimanenti
volta che vengo qui c'è un piano in più
hanno alimentato da per piangere questa
era la
questa era la base per poter spiare i
nemici o leggere pro è diventato di
diano perché tutto spaccare tutto
l'albero perchè la cespuglio si spaccava
da solo giustamente ok in questa è la
pellicola è il meno 1 questo è il piano
terra e questo è più uno che va bene c'è
il letto bella faccia mi ha lasciato due
diamanti e ci siamo fatti infatti il
piccone quello che aspetta una mano ci
sta vagliando procedura nella fascia di
parma per noi quanti diamanti ha trovato
perché in crescita della domanda che mi
ha lasciato due diamanti trovati un
botto l'uomo è incredibile sarà quindi
devi fare una piscina comunque una
jacuzzi na per la vista sul lago
allora faccio qua sopra quella
riferimenti la casa va bene si
immobiliare su mike volevo provare a
esplorare vicino a casa nostra che qua
ci stanno ancora di bambù cairo non devi
rompere il bambù ma allora chi 64 bambù
che ti ho dato prima sai da dove li ho
presi può avere continuiamo ragazzi
andiamo avanti
mentre brucia a casa ma cosa vuole non è
facile
va bene uguale a casa ma pensa un box
scena di speciale quesito cosa più bella
di minecraft tempio
così sta roba è costruita su questo no
ma no no no ma di base in mai capito che
non c'era sicuramente conto ma è raro e
non c'è non è che si trovano proprio una
costruito qualcuno questo non ha
costruito nessuno queste provinciali di
trovarne uno scudo allora ce ne sono
nelle giungle però vanno cercati
parecchio amaro che figata
le dita diciamo che non è semplicissimo
bellezza certo non ho le torce aspetta
in verità nostri ma decide senza allora
ci sono pericoloso e non ho idea non ho
mai fatto un giorno giorni sono delle
leve leggero tutte tirate tutte amico
ciao ho detto sei sparita
se spera d'occhio aia che vale e mameli
tirata tu no no no perché c'è una corda
più per terra quando ci pare si saprà
spara una freccia piccole quasi
invisibile che ci sono da vicino il vero
spara la prese come faccio devono aias
impazza ha beccato veroli faccio un giro
senti basta ragazzi di una festa
cosa c'è oggi noti pre allora un baratto
di un baratto un baratto un baratto nora
sorella un barattolo la sella la prendo
la sella la prendi tu no ma incredibile
troviamo solo pelle io prendo l'armatura
ancora e donatella ok diamanti ce lo
aspettiamo
no prendi tu ti prendi noi ma voi siete
i migliori amici e aveva breve la stella
di la sala gratis
qui ho preso altri due diamanti al
cinema
simile ai a spacca la scusa
spostatevi meglio tanto più che allora è
incredibile fini si è sì così gratis e
san precario ma anche io ho trovato una
stella completamente a caso l'ultima
volta meno male dove tenetevela mi
sembra impossibile magari non fa
supercomodo e stephen andiamo a cercare
è vicino a casa dice ci sono i fratelli
dalla nando aspetta questi rumori sono
di blocchi che si aprono sia perché gli
spiace 6 poi cos'altro si sicuro io non
gli ho mai esplorati questi tempo si
bisogna schiacciarle tirarli in una
certa quando fa questo rumore è perché
ci sono dei blocchi che ieri tolgono e
si spostano ok
perciò dovere sta spostando esatte credo
ci vediamo ma dove però provava a
qualcuno lo può fare secondo me no però
vai vai di nuovo allora io continuo a
sentirli ma qui non si muove niente
ecco ecco mai mai mai di farlo rifarlo
l'ho trovato equa ok dal resto cosa
faccia equa questo qua ce ne sono altri
da muovere che si tenne scomparire nel
ricompare 1 a provar ieri abbassare
quella va bene allora questo ha
abbassato qualcos'altro insomma il altro
ancora
ascolta ma ecco ecco non ce l'hanno
fatta un'altra casa
ecco attaccando tutto un altro aspetto è
che starò vola poi prenderemo anche
l'armatura allora ma dai
io prendo solo tre o quattro palle
prepara ora perfetto e lasciati per
terra ma scrivono facciamo prima a
scavare di terra tutto e chi se ne frega
però puoi pregare e rompere tutto però
non sappiamo dove non sappiamo dove era
cioè esatta per i pazienti muore vi ho
capito dove si trovava bellissimo nome
ragazzi incredibile sono troppo contento
che forse ho fatto una figata è una
figata tremenda ragazzi incredibile
valenza ricchi bello bello
tutto in un episodio ci sia altro in
tutto provato scavare a caso ma niente
quindi possiamo uscire da regalare
ok ok per te bello bello bello bello
bello
se c'è qualcosa alla fine visto ma
comunque che erano veramente vicina cina
vicinissima a casa anzi addirittura poi
finita giunga c'è il mare aperto dove si
potrebbero essere quelli sott'acqua dite
no vabbè è assurdo quello che lo ricordo
ma io voglio andare l'esplosione
prossimi bisogno dei vivi wow
no ragazzi bellissimo va bene con questo
tramonto incredibile yo yo concludere ai
ragazzi è una cosa molto romantica
abbiamo trovato dei diamanti ci siamo
spartiti
anzi mi sorprende tutti io andiamo a
portare questa roba fernando poi la
prossimo episodio ma nel mentre io vi
ringrazio di essere amici miei con
questo bellissimo e molto romantico
adesso
[Musica]